I think there are times when I i if you
like i underst I think I understand
things that are going on around me
because because of the work I do so I
understand maybe some of the dynamics of
in groups and some processes like
leadership a little bit better and in
particular I think I'm sensitive to when
I feel that other people who are trying
to achieve a particular outcome like
persuade someone or influence and maybe
do it wrong because they don't recognize
the importance of things like shared
identity for those processes and they
think for example it's just a question
of giving people information never is
it's always a question about building
identity first but you know I think I
think in terms of myself as an
individual and as a human being I think
I probably make all the same mistakes as
everybody else I don't I would did it
were that I if you like that Mike the
process of doing research had
obliterated all character faults and all
the kind of limitations of certain sorts
of identities from the face of mine
psychology but it really hasn't